P is the center of the green arc so this
is P right over here
the measure of angle P is 0.4 radians
and the length of the radius is 5 units
the length of the radius is 5 units
that's this length right over here find
the length of the green arc so just to
kind of conceptualize this a little bit
P you could imagine as the center of
this larger circle is a larger circle
and this angle right over here that has
a measure of 0.4 radians it intercepts
this a green arc right over here in
order to figure this out and actually I
encourage you to pause this video now
and try to think about this question on
your own how long is this arc given the
information that they've given us well
all we have to do is remind ourselves
what a Radian is one way to think about
a Radian is if you look at the arc that
the angle intercepts which is this green
arc and you think about its length the
length of this green arc is going to be
0.4 radii one way to think about radians
is if this if this angle is 0.4 radians
that means that the arc that it
intercepts is going to be 0.4 radii long
so this length we could write a 0.4
radii radii or radius assistance but
radii is the proper term now we don't
want our length in terms of radii we
want our length in terms of whatever
units the radius is this these kind of
five units well we know that each radius
has a length of five that our radius of
the circle has a length of five so this
is going to be 0.4 radii times five and
you know they just call it units right
over here times five I'll put it in
quotes because it's kind of a generic
term five units per / radii so what's so
the radii cancel out we're left with
just the units which is what we want so
0.4 times 5 is 2 so this is going to
give us
this is going to be equal to two so just
as a refresher again that when the the
angle measure in radians one way to
think about it is the arc that it
intercepts that's going to be this many
radii long well if each radius is five
units it's going to be zero point four
times five units long or two